en un comunicado salido de la Cumbre de
kiaf el presidente del Consejo europeo
Charles Michelle y la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula Van Der ley n
dijeron que el bloque actuará en
concordancia con el derecho europeo y
con el derecho internacional sin embargo
no está claro si esto es posible en la
práctica el análisis de este tema es con
Alberto hushter quien Ese es el doctor
de relaciones internacionales y autor de
varios libros sobre geopolítica doctor
bienvenido Gracias por estar en France
24 Gracias
se puede obligar a Rusia a pagar por la
reconstrucción de Ucrania tendrían que
hacer expropiaciones y esto además en un
contexto en el que Rusia no se pudiera
defender es plausible
mire Ángela Yo creo que la situación es
compleja porque lo que uno observa y
recién lo vimos en el discurso de la
presidente de la comisión europea es que
hay un gran esfuerzo de occidente
en tanto en acción como en pensamiento
en continuar con la guerra es decir
sería interesante que en paralelo a este
esfuerzo por reconstruir Ucrania
eventualmente eventualmente también
existiera alguna posibilidad de de
lograr algún cese de fuego no digo un
acuerdo porque las posiciones de Rusia y
Ucrania en el terreno están muy
enfrentadas muy encontradas lo que me
parece difícil o bastante incomprensible
por ahora es que no haya algún tipo de
línea que pase por la diplomacia y el
segundo lugar no hay una un consenso
universal en relación con utilizar
activos de Rusia es básicamente pasan
por las reservas del Banco Central Ruso
y por activos de personas no hay una un
consenso universal hay una una situación
que podríamos decir de confiscación de
occidente de activos de Rusia y para
utilizar esos estos activos de una
manera es más lícita digamos bueno va a
ser necesario conseguir un consenso
mayor puesto que si no sería
verdaderamente una una apropiación y por
parte de occidente y esto generaría más
problemas en relación a la situación
post de posguerra que tampoco es
demasiado tratada Más allá del tiempo
que puede llegar a durar esta guerra
Alberto justamente una de las opciones
que se plantean es la de utilizar las
reservas confiscadas de Rusia como usted
mencionaba pero este este dinero digamos
que está secuestrado o está congelado
podría servir también en el futuro para
negociar en términos de paz con Rusia y
ahí es donde nos adentramos en ese
escenario posguerra que usted nos
dilucidaba valdría la pena perder esa
posibilidad de utilizar estas reservas
que han sido confiscadas como una carta
de negociación futura con Rusia
bueno es una de las posibilidades para
para un futuro que por ahora no se ve
porque en estas en estas situaciones que
se escuchan en estas visitas a Estados
por parte por ejemplo ayer del
presidente Celestia pareciera también
que la guerra está pronto a terminar y
yo no sé si la guerra va a terminar
pronto a menos que haya una una ofensiva
por alguna de las dos partes que deje a
la otra parte en una situación realmente
comprometida como para pensar en una
decisión militar yo creo que la guerra
tiene más formas de guerra de trinchera
paralelamente hablando con la Primera
Guerra Mundial que una que un alcance de
de pronto en materia de de acuerdo por
lo tanto yo creo que
está bien pensar en cómo reconstruir
Ucrania que está realmente destruida
pero también yo creo que sería
interesante pensar en qué podemos vamos
a hacer ahora para para detener esta
situación que ha afectado la seguridad
humana de una manera tremenda Y esto no
está presente y mientras esto no esté
presente la guerra Va a continuar de
manera que repito Me parece interesante
ver cómo qué qué activos se utilizan y
la forma en que se hace porque Repito no
hay un consenso universal en relación
con utilizar activos de Rusia en este
caso porque se considera que violentó el
derecho internacional cosa que es cierto
pero este va a hacer falta algo más que
occidente se ponga de acuerdo va a ser
falta una política de alcance mundial y
así lo establezca porque si no va a
continuar el tema de la situación de
conflicto en el nivel estratégico entre
Rusia y occidente bueno todo esto son
escenarios hipotéticos es un plan que
lanza la Unión Europea que ha sido muy
popular que cuenta con apoyos pero que
eventualmente no estaría tampoco
definido ahora además es de las éticas y
de legalidad alrededor de este plan que
tanto ha lanzado Charles Michelle cabe
preguntarse si alcanzan los activos que
han sido sancionados Cuánto puede costar
reconstruir Ucrania después de un
conflicto que como ustedes dicen ni
siquiera sabemos cuándo va a terminar al
momento las cifras ya pasan por los 750
mil millones de euros
mire la cifra que da usted es la que yo
he considerado he leído en otros en
otras fuentes de manera que es una cifra
que supera con creces supera con creces
la los activos que
ha confiscado occidente hasta hoy de
Rusia que repito son activos
centralmente o la mayor parte de estos
activos Son
son es dinero de bancos y básicamente
del Banco Central
Yo diría que esto no sumará más de
300.000 millones de euros y estamos
hablando de una de un costo de
reconstrucción superior a los 600.000
millones de euros de manera que es un
escenario complejo el de la
reconstrucción No es cierto pero yo
repito pienso que Europa en paralelo a
esta tarea a esta tarea que va a ser muy
difícil lograr
no está concentrándose en el tema que
hoy debe concentrarse que es lograr
algún tipo de consenso relativo con un
cese de hostilidades Claro pero es que
terminar la guerra en este momento
implicaría de plano una pérdida de
territorio para Ucrania y una victoria
aunque fuera parcial para Rusia y Bueno
ahí están las discusiones no y pues hoy
veíamos a bolodimir selensky haciéndolo
hoy en Bruselas y pidiendo nuevamente la
ayuda con este último tema de los jets
de combate pero de otra parte sea como
sea en algún momento Ucrania va a tener
que pasar por un proceso de
reconstrucción y de reparación Europa no
solamente ha sufrido en su economía como
consecuencia de la guerra Por sus
efectos colaterales sino que también
pues sufre porque está financiando de su
bolsillo los fondos para la guerra y
estos fondos no son eternos no da para
pensar que además de eso cuando termine
la guerra puedan financiar una
reconstrucción futura Porque además
Ucrania ni siquiera es parte del bloque
Qué opciones cree usted que habría en un
futuro
bueno Yo diría que las opciones usted lo
dijo al principio van a tener que
necesariamente pasar por un por un
camino realista porque es verdad la
guerra es la posibilidad de poner fin a
la guerra no está cerca y posiblemente
esa posibilidad de de de de alcanzar Un
fin pasa por tratar el tema que dio
comienzo a la guerra las cuestiones
geopolíticas Y si esta guerra comenzó
por cuestiones geopolíticas el fin de la
guerra necesariamente va a ser
geopolítico porque si se piensa en una
construcción
mientras está enviando armas K que
desafían cada vez más la posibilidad de
extender la guerra porque ya se han
aprobado por ejemplo en Estados Unidos
sistemas misilísticos superiores a los
150 kilómetros esto significa que ya se
pasó a otro segmento de la guerra puesta
puesto que ahora Ucrania puede atacar en
retaguardia de Rusia de modo que lo que
está ocurriendo actualmente
Yo diría que está conspirando contra
esta posibilidad de alcanzar acuerdos
que permitan reconstruir Ucrania puesto
que está como está la situación en el
terreno la situación el escenario Es
peligroso porque más bien plantea la
posibilidad de una extensión de la
guerra puede ocurrir un incidente que
finalmente pluralice la guerra es decir
Rusia que no va a aceptar jamás una
derrota Puede crear una situación donde
la otan se vea más involucrada de manera
que
Considero que lo que hay que tratar es
el tema presente el de la guerra porque
si no las posibilidades de
reconstrucción de dinero etcétera van a
quedar demasiado para un futuro que no
sabemos cómo puede ser